Yeah. Good afternoon, guys.
Good afternoon.
Do you know,
Nigerians are really funny people.
Really, really funny. Like,
so yesterday I put out a video and
about the new immigration policy that was announced by
the UK government,
which is to take effect from 2024 Spring,
which is, by my estimation, is April.
So a lot of some
few people came around and were like,
Nigerians. And I don't start a game.
I don't start a game.
Try to. Why are we trying to educate Nigerians on
the fact that there has been a new law?
So they are trying to say that we should stop saying it.
The point is
we should stop informing Nigerians
some of the happening.
Some of the
things that are currently happening in the UK.
So the information I was released yesterday is, um.
It's an information that is very,
very important and um,
there's not an information that, um,
should not be talked about,
you understand?
So guys, take a chill,
relax, relax.
You understand?
So we just trying to like,
educate ourselves
and let our dreams know what the options are and
what they can do going forward.
So I haven't said all that. So, um,
I did a little research as to um,
what informed, like,
what informed the British government into taking
that decision
to try to like,
take the decision on cortelling immigrants,
like having more immigrants coming into the country
and even if you are even here,
restricting You
to the level in which you don't.
You might even be surprised.
You just have to leave the country after your,
the expiration of your visa
because you might not even qualify
to even apply for an extension.
I decided to like
Dev into, um,
get more information and research more.
So I went into the office of the National Statistics,
like, just like
the Nigerian
of Nigeria statistics.
So they have
the office of National Statistics in the UK.
That's where you could get information
relating to the influent outflow of
immigrant citizens
and all the people.
So I. The information there was really,
really baffling.
Like, I was baffled.
I had to pull out this information
so I could share with her.
Share with everyone that cares to.
To listen to this video.
As in the year 2020,
the immigration figure
for the order of 2020
is 2.819 million people.
That people that came into the country in the
all over 2020.
And the immigration figure
that is the people
to the number of people that left the country
is 2.41 million people.
Then in 2021,
the whole of
immigration
people that came to the country
was 3.107 million people
and people that left the country was
1.844 million people.
In 2022, it was 4.472 million people.
People that left in
within that same year
is 1.886 million people.
So this year
2023, as at June,
this figure is just a sad June.
We have already had 2.382 million people
as against people that Left
within the same period,
1.005 million people.
So at the end of this four year period,
total population
of immigrants that came into the UK.
And when I mean immigrants,
I'm not talking about just Nigerians,
I'm talking about globally,
like everybody.
Even from Ukraine,
the war in Ukraine,
Pakistan, Indians,
Nigerians, everybody.
Put in total,
for the period of that.
That four year period,
we had a total of
12.78 million people.
In four years?
Yeah. In four years,
12.78 million people came into the UK
and we have
7.145 million people
who left the UK.
So at the end of the period,
we have a total net migration figure of
5.635 million people
currently in the UK.
So these are the figures that
was used in
making that decision.
And in making that decision.
I just want to put this out there.
That is not because
did a video on YouTube or Twitter or TikTok
that made the UK government to take that decision. No,
please, let's stop misleading people.
People not say
stop posting on YouTube,
stop posting,
stop talking about. No,
that is not
yet you government is not that your focus is on.
Your focus is on data.
These are the data that they using taking
in making informed decision.
So it's just unfortunate that some Nigerians are not
enlighting or educated to that level.
Thinking that is because somebody did a video on the.
Trying to educate the people on what's.
What is currently happening in and around The UK,
you understand what is even comes to video.
The honest truth is
if you go on YouTube,
Nigerians are not even off to
2% of people sharing contents.
Jackbar contents
instead of travelling contents on YouTube.
I'm telling you,
go to YouTube,
you see Indians,
you see Bangladesh,
you see Pakistan's.
We're not even able to.
I can guarantee you that we're not even.
Not to just type anything on YouTube,
how many Nigerians you will see.
So please guys,
this is information I just want to put out there
and just to educate us that these are the numbers.
The UK, are they really justified giving these numbers?
5.6 million people within the space of four years
currently in the UK,
are they justified or in taking this decision
that is definitely gonna affect the life
so far immigrants.
So thank you guys.
It's your choice to make.
Are they right?
I'm not gonna see anything regarding
if they're right or wrong.
So guys, thank you guys.
Help me kindly like and share this video
and God bless you.